I can't think driving my pads Ryu for  legal reasons I'm gonna need a  transcript of everything you could  possibly say during a match  sure yeah my hurricane kick a tech tech  Ruka high tops in the blue cap no no  it's a tie Jake fruga  I heard Chex Mix that time do you have  some sort of endorsement deal with Chex  Mix over high tops I don't wear shoes  man that wouldn't make sense but I've  seen stranger things  Blanca does an antiperspirant you and I  both know that you don't know what  you're saying so for all you know maybe  it means like I think oh god my example  was bad it's it's an ancient Japanese  word so it's really hard to spell with  English letters uh-huh okay why don't I  just draw Dora the Explorer giving a  someone the finger that's gonna make you  mad  dude okay I think I have one legal sent  this over it says you your face if close  enough I'm kicking this [ __ ] you know I  mean you just have to read it sorry  wrong show